Gavin Newsom is playing good guy while
they figure out that situation it's
fairly obvious and it's clear also that
they have tasked him with going after
the number one threat and who is that
number one threat yeah it's Florida man
himself Ron DeSantis we showed you this
clip a day or two ago but I think it's
worth repeating to just see the
dishonest attacks coming out of Cali
towards free Florida
these flights of Asylum Seekers that are
being brought to Sacramento there have
been two of them now they've been
described as state-sanctioned kidnapping
by the Attorney General of of this state
of California you tweeted directly at
the governor of Florida Ron DeSantis I
want to get this right you called him a
small pathetic man and asked quote
kidnapping charges is that is that what
you believe happened Governor from the
Florida kidnap migrants and brought them
to California I think I've been generous
small and pathetic
very generous he's just weakness
masquerading his strength
yeah he's flailing
desperate
he's so weak masquerading his strength
he's so flailing that this place is
freaking expanding like you wouldn't
believe everybody keeps want to come
here keeps wanting to come here keeps
moving here keeps buying houses here
keeps bringing businesses here keeps
enjoying our beautiful weather and our
low taxes and our uh you know we don't
get fire raining from the sky which is
what they get in California because this
idiot doesn't know anything about fire
management either in Forest management
and all that stuff but this is what he
does okay you guys get it so now let's
continue because then he was as we just
showed you he was on Hannity last night
and again he went after to say just
doing the job of the Biden
Administration
we're told they had jobs they told they
were going to get certain court dates
changed they were dropped off they
knocked on the door and they left and
there was not coordinated I mean what
kind of Faith tradition everything else
there was a video of the people getting
on the because they were all lied to and
told and they were being taken care of
everything's going to be great I would
be proud and happy then then because by
the way I have the RFP because they
landed in your Sanctuary State you're
going to take care of them they should
be happy look we'll we'll deal with the
car come on this is California I know
it's okay
on this way the fourth largest economy
in the world we can handle of course we
have this okay I'm a border state Rhonda
Santos is not I know he's desperate to
get into the ACT no because a lot of
belly flop Donald Trump is going to
clean the Joe Biden DeSantis belly
flocked he will clean his clock I don't
have a crystal attention and he set this
up months ago by doing an RFP I have the
contractor okay my question he tried to
hire saying he was going to send people
to California this is a stunt it's
embarrassing it's not pathetic
I think he did the right thing his
State's not a sanctuary well Joe Biden
just wanted to help people will you
apply the same standard to Joe Biden
he's flying all these illegal immigrants
coordinating them coordinating excuse me
I'm engaged directly with the
administration at 3 30 in the morning in
Westchester Airport not LaGuardia not
Kennedy Westchester you know why because
they're sneaking them in when States
aren't looking and cannot be perfect but
they're coordinating there's a different
Spirit there's a different level of
Engagement level it's different in
daylight and darkness it's not perfect
there's some humility in this well isn't
Joe Biden dumping people in Florida all
these other states doesn't dumb people
anywhere what's the difference between
whatever is doing what the Santa's
manipulation hey Sean Hannity I'm going
to shoot you a text after the show today
you did a bang up great job there you
did not let him get away with any of
this BS you see what he says there at
the end you know every now and again
when they accidentally tell you what
they really think there's a different
spirit so when Joe Biden when they let
illegals into Texas and they Rampage
through El Paso and some of these border
towns and we see that they're taking
over the airports and crime goes up and
they bring drugs and they're raping
women and doing all of those things but
nobody cares about it it doesn't get on
the mainstream media except Fox although
if you send a few of them up to Martha's
Vineyard then all hell breaks loose
right uh but the spirit it's a little
different of spirit